bienvenidos estábamos haciendo la
transformada de la plaza del seno de
arte pero nos quedamos sin tiempo esta
es la definición de la transformada de
laplace de seno de la tdt y esto lo
definimos como ye
y vamos a hacer una integración por
parte de dos veces entonces aquí están
les dije también que no se preocupen por
los límites al menos de la integral
vamos a hacerlo ya al final
vamos a preocuparnos por la versión
indefinida de y vamos a imaginar que
esta parte es una integral indefinida
entonces podremos evaluar los límites
bueno llegamos a este punto donde nos
dimos cuenta que tenemos después de
haber hecho dos integrales por partes o
dos integraciones por partes nos dimos
cuenta de que este término es nuestra
idea original si no tomamos en cuenta
los límites vemos que esta es la
transformada de la plaza de seno de ate
así que bueno ahora vamos a cambiar de
colores y esto bueno de hecho esto es
que esto es igual allí
esta es nuestra definición original
ahora vamos a agregar a cuadrada / s
cuadrada en
ambos lados de la igualdad y esto es
igual a más voy a agregar este término
más a cuadrada entre s cuadrada
que es igual
ahora ese término ya lo quitamos vamos a
trabajar con esto entonces y lo podemos
simplificar
vamos a factorizar una menos para menos
7 - al menos 7 x
el seno
bueno de hecho a ver vamos a ver uno
entre ese seno de ate
- 1 / s cuadrada coseno de a d
espero no haber cometido algún error
esto podemos agregarle el coeficiente
tenemos uno más a cuadrada entre s
cuadrada james es lo mismo que si
escribo ese cuadrado masa cuadrada entre
s cuadrada
todo esto es igual a
- al menos siete por uno entre ese seno
de seno de al menos uno entre s cuadrada
coseno arte
y ahora esto es una constante ya que
estamos trabajando todo con respecto a
ti aquí no hay ninguna t así que sólo
podemos tener como una constante y ahora
vamos a hacer la evaluación de límites
en este otro lado donde tenemos los
términos de t y después veremos el
resultado de este otro lado una vez que
ya hemos terminado de evaluar los
límites de nuestra integral impropia así
que vamos a tener aquí que los límites
los vamos a evaluar cuando y bueno aquí
les puedo decir que podemos haber
llevado todo esto de los límites desde
el principio pero nos hubiera complicado
mucho el estar trabajando con estos
términos así que ahora vamos a ver la
parte derecha de nuestra evaluación de
límites que es cuando te tiende a
infinito qué pasa qué pasa cuando
entiende al menos infinito aquí vamos a
tener que este término de menos sea la
menos 7 va a aproximarse a 0
x lo que tenemos aquí entre paréntesis
bueno vemos que el seno que se aproxima
al infinito y el coche no que se
aproxima al infinito van a estar
oscilando sin embargo este término de es
el que va a dominar todo esto que está
aquí si esto lo multiplicamos por cero
no importa que aquí todo va a estar x
cero así que nos va a quedar este
término cuando te tiende a infinito como
cero lo cual tiene sentido ya que éstos
van oscilando entre uno y menos uno y no
importa esto que tanto oscile al estar x
cero pues va a ser igual a cero y al
menos infinito tiene muy rápidamente a
llegar a cero pero bueno no quiero
enfocarme demasiado en esto ustedes
pueden pensar al respecto en su propio
tiempo libre así que tenemos cero menos
todo esto evaluado cuando te es igual a
cero que es menos al menos ese por cero
o menos
a la 0 todo esto es igual a 1 por lo que
se convierte en más 1 x ahora en 100
menos
1 / s cuadrada coseno de cero
bueno el coseno de 0 va a ser igual a 1
así que esto es menos 1 / s cuadrada
- 1 / s cuadrada
y esto todo esto va a ser igual a
- 1 / s cuadrada y creemos que cometimos
un error aquí
porque no debería tener un término
negativo acá así que vamos a regresar
para ver en donde me equivoqué este es
un número negativo
él es tercero
- aquellos 0 aquí es un -1
entonces ya sea que este es un menos o
este es un más
al menos st ya ya ha habido donde me
equivoqué desde acá cuando factores de
la menos a la menos act
esto está bien pero aquí dejé un símbolo
negativo en lugar del símbolo positivo
ya que quite el término negativo así que
esto es un más esto de aquí es un más
bueno al menos no fue algo muy difícil
de encontrar así que esto es un más y
esto también es un más y qué bueno
porque estaría realmente muy triste
después de haber desperdiciado dos
vídeos trayendo un error de signo así
que tenemos ese cuadrado más a cuadrada
entre ese cuadrado x james que es igual
a 1 / s cuadrada y ahora vamos a
multiplicar ambos lados por el inverso
de esto y nos va a quedar 10 igual a 1
entre ese cuadrado
déjenme revisar si esto está correcto 1
/ s cuadrada
y es igual a 1 / s cuadrada por s
cuadrado sobre s cuadrada más cuadrada
estos dos se cancelan pero déjenme ver
si no me volví a equivocar
porque tengo este sentimiento de que
volví a equivocarme por aquí
vamos vamos a ver si aquí tengo otro
error en este término
y espero que no les moleste que esté
corrigiendo esto sobre la marcha pero es
que así es como lo estoy desarrollando
sobre la marcha en caso de que tuvieran
alguna duda al respecto volví a hacer lo
mismo me equivoqué al sacar esto como
factor aquí este es un más pero es a / s
cuadrada es una app
aquí también va a haber una
y aquí abajo esto es una
aquí es una aquí también fue una así que
nos quedamos con la respuesta correcta
ahora sí aja / s cuadrada más cuadrada
espero que no nos haya desconcentrado
mucho todos los errores de descuido que
tuve aquí pero este tipo de cosas
suceden cuando estamos haciendo
integrales por partes dos veces con todo
un conjunto de variables pero ya tenemos
otro registro dentro de nuestra tabla de
transformadas de laplace que es la
transformada de la plaza me quedo muy
coreada vamos a escribir la de nuevo la
transformada de la plaza del seno de ate
es igual a
am / s cuadrada más cuadrada
y este es un registro muy significativo
los invito a que ustedes ahora hagan por
su cuenta la transformada de la plaza
del coseno de ate y como tip les diré
que va a quedar ese sobre ese cuadrada
masa cuadrada y notarán que pues hay una
simetría entre estos dos resultados de
todas maneras ya terminé con esta
transformada y estoy bastante cansada
con esto así que nos vamos a ver en el
siguiente vídeo